[Music]
[Applause]
Dean Blake does it again
twenty-three-year-old Chloe Kochanski
from Nashville Tennessee took home the
top prize on Tuesday season finale of
The Voice after Chloe dazzled the
audience and Blake showed off his
sexiest man alive coat the pair headed
backstage where a teen was front and
center I truly think Chloe can go on
from here and become the really the
first superstar let's not even take it
that far let's just say star the first
star that we've had come out of this
show that can have some hit songs and
stuff I do think you can be a superstar
I'm just trying not to hex this this
thing how do you not want to own a
record that has her voice on it
that's something is wrong with you
something's physically wrong with you if
you don't want that right I believe you
know Blake when he says that um you know
he does take care of his his team and
his people that he works with and you
know whatever that would have looked
like even if that was just being able to
pick up the phone and ask for advice I
think that that would have been
something that would have happened
regardless of winning so I'm very stoked
that we won this together that's very
fun but regardless I think we would have
you know worked together and you know
like keep it going and it's not just
it's not just for the show it's real
[Music]
you